it is July 24 2023 and you're watching
the code report I regret to inform you
that the Twitter bird logo was
euthanized this morning and replaced
with this x logo it was designed by some
random Twitter user highly inspired by
Unicode and is accompanied by this intro
video that uses a glitch animation
effect that went out of style five years
ago this is clearly a genius 25d chess
move by Elon but the big question is why
is it just a hoax to draw attention to
the platform is he deliberately trying
to kill Twitter is it because the new
website uses htmx or is it part of some
other Grand strategy that we can't even
begin to wrap our heads around a few
months ago I made a video about how
Twitter open sourced its code and it
turns out that was a big mistake because
Zuckerberg forked that code and launched
threads which was able to gain over 100
million users in just a few days making
it the fastest growing social media app
of all time Mark Zuckerberg is an
absolute genius he created Facebook
which was the first social media site
for friends but wait that was stolen
from Myspace but he was the first person
to create Instagram stories for short
content that disappears or actually wait
they stole that from Snapchat but he did
create reels or short video content that
can go go viral quickly oh wait he stole
that from Tick Tock which itself stole
from Vine which coincidentally used to
be owned by Twitter and was shut down in
2017. meta Engineers even have their own
special keyboards to build these
features but threads has a big problem
graphic is already down 70 from the peak
two weeks after its launch and it's
already got one foot in its grave right
next to Blue Sky Mastodon and parlor
it's pro-censorship and doesn't allow
adult content but worst of all it forces
you to look at content from the
mainstream media and from a bunch of
cringe influencers you don't follow you
see Twitter is for smart ugly people
while Facebook and Reddit are for dumb
ugly people then we've got Instagram and
Tick Tock for hot dumb people and then
finally threads was going to fill the
gap for the Hot smart people
unfortunately there's just not enough
Hot smart people in the world to make it
work in addition Elon delivered a solid
counter punch to threads last week by
making the first Revenue share payments
to creators one of my favorite meme
accounts internet Hall of Fame got a
six-figure paycheck for simply curating
stupid content on the internet in
contrast meta doesn't do Revenue sharing
with their creators the only thing you
get from meta is fake Internet cloud and
that means if you want to make money you
have to go to platforms like only fans
but now let's get back to this name
change why would Twitter Rebrand to X
Elon loves the letter X you've got
SpaceX the Tesla Model X and even his
own kid X Ash Archangel 12. at first I
thought this was all just a joke but I
confirmed on my phone that the actual
icon has changed it looks like X is
supposed to represent a universal Media
company that handles all forms of
content that Rivals platforms like
Instagram and YouTube while providing a
universal place for journalists to post
content and compensating them for it
elon's been talking about making it an
everything bagel ever since he bought it
last year in fact the concept is very
similar to WeChat in China Elon even
said so himself his retracts Kick-Ass my
idea would be like how about if we just
copy WeChat hey but WeChat is basically
just a giant surveillance tool for the
Chinese government on top of that
digital privacy is under attack from
multiple angles worldcoin just launched
today and it's gonna come scan your
balls and give you a digital identity in
exchange for some cryptocurrency c2pa
wants to require every media file to be
digitally signed and this new web
integrity API proposal wants to add
digital Rights Management to every web
browser and based on its GitHub issues
people seem to really be liking that
idea I think the only solution is that
we start over and build a brand new
internet called internet X this has been
the code report thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one